[Musique]
bonsoir
je suis daniel où l'oeil je suis à gries
preneur je suis paysan je vis à l'ouest
de la côte d'ivoire dans une commune
rurale qui s'appelle dans l'année il
abat cultivent la terre
dilemme des ports
ds lite pour vous aujourd'hui remontant
sur scène j'ai décidé de vous parler
avec le coeur
vous savez quand vous avez grandir dans
la campagne comme moi vous avez le temps
de voir de grandes greniers remplies de
récolte des hangars plein
chan
le drian tout ça c'est de la pauvreté
therrien sous silence des agriculteurs
glissante de l'afub distance
à devenir agriculteur quand vous êtes
fils d'agriculteur
dans mon parcours j'ai vu des erreurs
dix jeunes
arrêté
mais j'ai aussi vu des pales amaury
parfois il est allé talent lorsqu'il
meurt c'est des bouleversements
quand notre célèbre
pat didier nous a été brutalement
arrachée d'un grand bouleversement en
côte d'ivoire moi mon plus grand
bouleversement c'est lorsque deux mondes
en soit vous demandez certainement qui
est dû en effet que c'est un ami un très
bon ami
ettinger une tribune ion
dans notre motion il était d'ailleurs le
publiant en deuxième année il a décidé
d'arrêter les études parce que son père
ne pouvait plus assurer les études
secondaires
des coûts universitaires étaient
beaucoup trop cher pour son père l'a
décidé de retourner à la terre
en 2015 gay a réalisé l'exploit
il avait 50 hectares de maïs un
production
mas 2015 j'ai visité son champ ce jour
là c'était le dima ce que je rencontrais
un vieux fier parce que là-bas 50
hectares de maïs en production il
promettait avoir son 12 tonnes environ
un chiffre d'affaires de 15 millions ttc
prévisions j'ai vu un jeune homme qui
rennais qui faisaient des projets qui en
vivent allait réinvestir parce que
d'enfants quinze jours ils devaient
récolter sa production
ce rejet en capital
après cent quinze jours j'ai reçu un
coup de fil de mon ami ils disent à
dépasser la prévision est finalement 130
tonnes à l'hectare
cris de singe ou après
je n'avais toujours pas vendu 180 francs
sans son fils joue après que n'avait
toujours pas vendu sur les côtes
les rongeurs ont commencé à taper part
parce qu'un effet il ne pouvait pas de
match
the national qui as est elle assez rural
dessus nos territoires s'est contenté
d'aller chercher les céréales un peu
plus loin dans des pays où l'on pratique
air l'agriculture de
nous l'appelons l'agriculture avec
beaucoup plus d'intrants chimiques
qui est moins cher on ne pouvait pas se
tait sale et comme c'est notre
territoire
deux ans il avait toujours sa production
d'un thé pour y arriver c'est chiant
andretti avec toute la pression que ne
pouvait plus supporter
sud et de prendre une décision de
jeunesse
tellement c'était sa dernière décision
il a voulu regagner l'europe
je sois là je n'ai plus jamais revenu
n'est pas arrivée en europe il est mort
en mer avec lui son rêve avec lui un
projet avec lui ses ambitions avec lui
son savoir-faire son génie sa créativité
mais le lendemain lorsque je me suis
réveillé
qui vit en moi
envie de réinventer l'activité agricole
j'avais envie de proposer un système
territorial tout ne plus afin que
d'autres groupes et habib la même
situation que mon amour j'ai appelé des
amis
commencez à réfléchir une idée de projet
ça nous a pris six mois après six mois
on savait exactement ce qu'on voulait
faire on a décidé de créer une
entreprise qui allait développer des
systèmes intégrés pour réduire les
pertes post-récolte vous permettre aux
jeunes au travers nos chaînes vague de
valeur de rester sur nos territoires et
de produits et gagner leur vie en avant
ses envies de permettre aux produits du
terroir d'atteindre les marchés de masse
ou dépasser les marchés de niche parce
que c'était là le défi on a décidé de
valider notre cohésion faisons une étude
massy nous sommes allés rencontrer le
plus gros cabinet d'abidjan
d'ailleurs le meilleur cabinet de
l'afrique de l'ouest
de fait nos trucs tubes comme ans après
ils nous ont appelés en soit il était 16
heures
ils m'ont informé que le projet ne
pouvait pas marcher
oui
à la dernière page il avait écrit ceci
très vite arrivé
ce soir là nous étions
le lendemain matin lorsque monsieur
leveillé j'ai appelé mes collaborateurs
et je le redis en continu
parce que pour moi on pouvait pas nous
reprocher d'avoir essayé
a décidé de continuer leur expliquer ce
qui est inscrit à la dernière page en
effet dans notre système intégré on
avait décidé d'ouvrir moulin un moulin
communautaire qui al'air valoriser être
transformé tous les vins vendus de
céréales sur notre territoire en
aliments pour le bétail
un de notre côté on avait envie de le
début de faire émerger un nouveau marché
pour les aliments donc créé une ferme
d'élevage de 10000 tête du port ou
confirmer la quasi totalité des aliments
qu'ils allaient sortir notre moulin
c'était ça me gêne parce qu'en côte
d'ivoire de 800 mille tonnes de
provoquer importés chaque année soit 4 5
milliards un chiffre d'affairé normes
qu'on investisse thème à l'importation
on avait envie de se positionner sur ce
marché mais notre que tu disais qu'une
tête porcine est très vite arrivée
en réalité est un secteur réservé
protégé par jour politique agricole
était passé par là parfois nous devait
toucher à ça parce qu'ils ne pèsent
porcine était capital
j'ai dit aux amours
à tête une phrase qui résonnait t'aidera
chaque difficulté c'est une opportunité
d'affaires mais il faut trouver
l'opportunité mais nous n'allons pas
arrêter
décidé de transformer notre ferme
initial qui devait produire les 10000
tête du port à une femme incubateur
sommes allés à l'ouest on a sélectionné
100 jeunes qu'ils avaient envie de se
lancer
l'équipe de chercheurs qu'ils
attendaient juste une opportunité mais
l'a reçu notre ferme on les a formés
gratuitement techniques d'élevage que
nous voulions et on leur a remis des
semences
gratuitement pour qu'ils puissent
s'installer
mon père en avait 100 fermes et six ans
ferme le cheptel minimum était sans tête
enfin dix minutes on non nous avions le
résultat que nous recherchions pour
lancer notre chaîne de distribution
on a décidé du partage et d'économie de
partager les risques
en effet c'est une peste porcine est
très vite arrivée nous n'essaierons
supporte plus les seuls à assumer
on a résolu nos trois problèmes en un
seul parce qu'en réalité on a permis à
fond une des 30 au musée on a permis à
notre moulin d'avoir 100 fermes où il
pouvait couler tranquillement la
production on a garanti notre certaines
des 10 novembre dernier nous avons lancé
un but dion la première chaîne de
distribution de porcs nourris et les
insultes et des pois et voilà
[Applaudissements]
le camp nou commence à nous arriver là
juste vous demander de m'écouter avec le
coeur c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
décidé ne pas vous faire passer des
flight
lors de va mourir et se voit n'avait pas
d'enfant mâle
en afrique les femmes ne pouvaient pas
si sûr des eaux troubles
avait un dilemme
fallait qu'il y ait un successeur
alors le roi a dit aux notables d'aller
dans le maillot mais de retrouver tous
les hommes vaillants et courageux qui
veulent être roi
le lendemain il y avait mille candidats
mille jeunes bihan et vaillants ils se
sont tous présentés à la cour royale
parce que généralement lorsqu il s'agir
de distinction lorsqu'il s'agit
de gloire on est généralement tous
candidats il y avait mille candidats
points seul fauteuil
le roi a demandé à ce que ces mille
jeunes soient départager
que la première épouse
et de l'envoyer lâchant pendant sept
jours et le 5è joue le roi allait
décider qui allait être roi
jo sans repos le soleil était au zénith
à la fin du troisième joue il y avait
seulement 500 personnes dans le champ
enfin du septième jour il y avait
seulement 100 personnes dans les champs
parce qu'en effet généralement nous
avons tous envie de percer mais quand
vient le moment de faire le travail pour
lequel nous avons été choisis quand
vient le moment de payer le prix
pourra-t-elle donc le sommet que nous le
cherchons nous dénonçons il est admis
mais à vouloir le fauteuil lui on l a
juste demandé de travailler l'été m
à la fin du 7ème jour il y avait franc
personne dans le champ
900 sont rentrés chez eux parce qu'ils
voulaient pas travailler
mais l'europe a besoin d'une seule
personne alors c'était la deuxième
épreuve que je viens vous dire à vous
dire pour ma part notre première preuve
c'est un autre étude marché comme
pouvait pas marcher parce qu'une case
porcine est très vite arrivée
nous avions le choix arrêter ou
continuer on a décidé de continuer
la deuxième épreuve le roi demande aux
notables et aux sages du royaume de
départager les enjeux alors les jeunes
ont été invités à déchiffrer les énigmes
et des problèmes
il y avait 10 juin dans la cour royale
parce qu'aujourd'hui dans le nouvel an
nous nous trouvons notre intelligence
sera mise à contribution parce que nous
sommes dans un monde de plus en plus
compétitive
le travail et le courage ne suffira pas
il va nous falloir de l'intelligence
l'intelligence financière de
l'intelligence économique de
l'intelligence sociale de l'intelligence
dans cette activité dans chaque domaine
activité où nous nous trouvons
il va nous falloir billes en publiant
que les autres tu sois là il y avait
seulement dix jeunes qui se sont
démarqués des saints
il y avait un seul fauteuil donc il
fallait départager
pour nous la clé de licence était de
pouvoir contourner ce problème et
partager les risques
le voir entrer dans sa cave trente
minutes après il est sorti avec ses
serviteurs avec 10 pouces et 10 grain et
à chaque jeune et l'a remis en poupe et
une graine il a dit partir venez sept
jours après avec des plans je vous dirai
qui sera le roi était le plugin épreuve
parmi eux il y avait un jeune qui
s'appelle là dedans
dans était un enfant était le fils d'un
ingénieur agronome
pleuve était censé gagner pour lui
arrivé à la maison dans
semer la graine d'impôt pour nous qui
sommes agriculteurs après deux jours et
demi
la graine elles sont ces germes et en
grains de maïs
après trois jours la graine de kits on
n'avait pas du tout géré mais là
problème
ses amis ont commencé à conseiller à
temps de changer sa graine offre il ya
quelque chose qui n'allait pas mais dans
avait une éducation noble il ne voulait
pas triché après quatre jours sa mère
est venue dans sa chambre temps mais lui
a dit monfils
l'éducation dont tu parles c'est moi qui
t'ai donné le ce soir là il s'agit de
royautés maman te demande plus une seule
fois dans a dit à sa mère maman je pense
que quand tu me donner cette éducation
toutes ses facultés
lui me manquait juste juste un peu juste
un peu corrompu
il a refusé d'être ici le septième jour
courageusement il se présenter à la cour
royale avec amp au vide
le nom offre au jeune homme avait des
plants de maïs et le peuple a commencé à
crier
amor amor amor parce que dans le commun
des mortels lorsqu'on fait des choses
différemment
on a l'impression que vous faites n'est
pas bien vous êtes fous que vous n'êtes
pas honnête
le roi l'a descendu de son trône dans
était au premier rang quand il a vu le
voit venir
il est passé au suivant leur demande au
premier chef la graine que je t ai remis
il a répondu oui mon seigneur et à
chaque fois que le roi avançait dans
reculé finalement le roi était en face
de la dixième personne il se mit à
genoux il a commencé à pleurer
il a dit monseigneur j'ai tout fait
mon père ingénieur agronome il m'a aidé
on a pu faire mais la graine a refusé de
fermer
dur à retourner sur son cône et il a dit
au peuple c'est ce jeune qui mérite
d'être convoi
parce qu'en réalité quand le retourner
dans sa cave
il a pris les graines il les a vaincus
quand vous savez la grève la semaine
street ne peuvent jamais géré mais en
fait c'était le tour de l'intégrité est
à l'épreuve de l'honnêteté d'un document
de plus en plus corrompus combien
sommes-nous aujourd'hui jeunes qui se
restaurent attachés à nos valeurs à nos
principes passe à la corruption passe à
tous que notre monde d'aujourd'hui un
calme
lorsque nous avons décidé de continuer
en soi
nous avons rencontré un homme en costume
que nous avait invités dans un hôtel de
la place à abidjan à l'hôtel ivoire
et nous avait proposé de faire quelque
chose
qui ne rentrait pas
or
refusé de faire
deux jours après le même monsieur m'a
appelé et m'a dit daniel
vous n'êtes pas nombreux ces jeunes à
qui au fait ce type de proposition et il
refuse en réalité j'avais envie de
savoir qui tu étais vraiment en réalité
ce monsieur il était le directeur
régional de la jeunesse emploi ions qui
dirigeait le fonds agit pour la jeunesse
en font du ministère le ministère de la
jeunesse en côte d'ivoire la semaine qui
a suivi en entreprise venait de signer
un contrat l'un des contrats les plus
importants de notre entreprise pour
permettre à 1000 jeunes encore dit voie
d'intégrer nos chaînes de valeur
parce que nous étions restés à passer à
nos valeurs
que je voulais vous dire pourquoi
que pour ma part
pour percer
le thème
paris
l'intelligence
l intégrité
[Musique]